for someone like you
you seem like you're a methodical guy
you see you're you know you're a chess
guy your dad's a chess person you know
five-time united armed force champion
five times six times indiana state you
were playing at five years old against
16 year olds you don't play chess
without being strategic thinking about
your next few moves correct so if you
don't
do anything
and bring lawyers in
to the market i've interviewed a lot of
people who are in the mob to the market
it sounds like they're right absolutely
but if you do and you defend yourself
you're not only doing it for yourself
but you're also doing it for others who
maybe don't have your kind of resources
to say correct hey this guy's willing to
stand up he kind of helped change the
law for me correct because the one case
it was the seeks against facebook that's
the case that helped them out
india years ago they don't like this
facebook group that had seeks uh it was
a secret facebook page so india told
facebook to take them off facebook took
them off
then seeks sued facebook that became the
precedence nice so somebody like you can
potentially set the new one against
section 230. absolutely we i certainly
have uh legal options being explored
and uh i don't want to say too much on
the podcast but legal options are
certainly being explored we'll see how
things progress across the next few
weeks but i have a very strong suspicion
i will end up back on the media
platforms and or they will offer them
back to me the question now at this
point is
if i even want them anymore which is a
unique question because a lot of people
still believe that you can only have a
significant presence in the world with
these social media platforms that's the
source of their power i believe there's
huge pressure behind the dam in regards
to the fact that everybody understands
that these places are tyrannical and
that they control ideas and that they
force narratives and i use
my wording as the matrix i call them the
matrix and people say why do you call in
the matrix and i say because they
project
a false version of reality in real time
that people subscribe to
if there wasn't an absolute blacklist on
all opposing views during covet 19 that
[ __ ] would never have gone on for as
long as it did it went on for as long as
it did and they managed to report a
false version of reality for so long
because you couldn't discuss the
opposing side we just talked about our
friend here who got banned for saying
something very sensible and logical so
when you get huge media companies that
can literally alter in reality
in real time by deleting the other side
of an argument they're creating
a matrix that's what i like to call it
so i call them the source of the matrix
so people understand this and there's
huge pressure behind the dam but the
problem is people say well what's the
alternative and i think if someone could
pave the way and put a crack in the dam
by maintaining massive relevancy
despite of a ban and still having a
social media platform and presence which
is respected on other platforms i think
it's gonna do them significant damage i
think the pressure and the crack
together is gonna create something
monumental and already i've moved to
rumble i only had 738 000 subscribers on
my youtube after five years of work post
ban i moved to rumble which is a youtube
competitor stock price has gone up 36
and i'm at five i'm at half a million
subscribers in two weeks so i'm about to
surpass the size of my youtube channel
within a month
um youtube stocks down rumble stock's
massively up
so all in all there's there's there's
there's there's other avenues but we'll
see i have i certainly agree with you
that what they've done to me is
massively unfair they know it's unfair i
think the reason they didn't send me an
email or any confirmation of what i did
wrong it's because they knew they would
end up in court and they didn't want to
be tied down to their reason they want
to stay fluid and try and make up a
reason on the day
uh i've heard from very reliable sources
that their terms of service have changed
significantly post my ban they've made
up new reasons post spam they've made a
bunch of new [ __ ]
so it's gonna be interesting but
certainly yeah there has to be legal
ramifications for what they've done i
don't take it personally but i do take
it professionally and you're right they
were wrong i have no reason to be banned
my instagram is just cars
it's just cars and and a little bit of
flexing there's no politics there's not
even any points of view i had no strikes
nothing it's just a hit piece if you
enjoyed this video and you want to watch
the entire podcast click over here and
if you want to be connected with experts
influencers such as kiyosaki tate
connolly palmeteri myself and others
download the app minect where you get a
chance to connect with these folks by
the minute you get to buy the minute or
have face times with them 15 minutes ask
them any questions you may want to have
download the admin act and start
connecting with influencers and experts
today
[Music]